Michelle during the break and that was
saying he's a sucker he's a sucker for
these kind of labels and I'm a mother of
three kids as soon as I hear that it's
grass-fed and organic I assume this is
better for my children and without
actually digging into a label I buy it I
agree I would as well I've always been
for years and years before it was
fashionable on the margin why not or on
the side of safety right now you're
never really totally sure but pesticides
hormones additives preservatives how can
they be great for you so but is it all
really true i mean we hear so many
examples now of people waiting labeling
foods gluten-free that well I shouldn't
say is it true but is it just a ploy
because so many foods are naturally
gluten-free they never had gluten in
them and now they throw that label on
them and all of a sudden sales rise
looks true but people who have a severe
gluten intolerance only one out of 133
Americans have a real severe gluten
intolerance and yet for some product
categories gluten-free products can be
as much as twenty to thirty percent of
the sales but for people who are
severely allergic who have very adverse
reactions they need to know that it's
it's gluten free and legislations been
passed and it's been put into effect to
make sure that products that say they're
gluten-free really are but it doesn't
feel like this gluten-free situation is
a bit of a fad I mean it seems like
every third person I dined with today is
gluten free yet four years ago they were
definitely throwing down pizza with me
true but on the margin again if they
think they feel better I don't know if
it'll stay for sure but some people
claim that they feel better whatever the
reaction is so why not why not do it
again I don't know if it will stay but
on the margin if you can if you can
choose between gluten free and not why
not pick gluten free all right well
these healthier options are more
expensive how can one deduce how much
healthier are they really ah you'll
never know unless there are tons and
tons of scientific experiments and
there's different degrees I know natural
wine i think is the next thing that
we're going to be talking a lot about
because there are tremendous amount of
sprays and secta sides on grapes and yet
it it's just grape juice so you think
it's natural so I think more and more
we're gonna find out really what's
becoming too clean is there I'm
we see for example the term organic on
everything but what does that actually
mean well it's certified organic and
that means that this soil is organic it
means it's not sprayed with pesticides I
think there's a certification process
for organic that's very meaningful it's
very much less clear for an all-natural
the all-natural definition is much more
fuzzy and less regulated and monitored
crafts recently announced that it was
going to be removing the artificial
orange and yellow dye from their
macaroni and cheese is that actually
going to have an impact on how much
macaroni and cheese they sell one would
argue the consumer who cares about
something like that wasn't buying Kraft
macaroni and cheese to begin with well
on the margin again versus the organic
versions I think people do look at
artificial flavors and colors they look
at artificial in agreeance statement so
now there's less of a difference between
Kraft macaroni and cheese and others and
so I think it actually could have so
you're you're behind the ear sucker like
me and Steph I think you're gonna come
on here and tell us it's all a scam and
we're all wasting our precious pennies
at the grocery store on these labels
that are so easy to just buy or print on
food that doesn't really hasn't really
changed I don't think it's a scam again
depending on what the certification is
there's different degrees of how well
regulated they are but I think again on
the margin I'd rather be safe than than
sorry and who knows then why are so many
of these companies these GMOs fighting
more labeling what the companies are
fighting them because the more stringent
you get the more bad things that can
come out so and it's more expensive it
is for them to produce and they have to
raise their prices and then they may
lose sales so there's some companies
that are fighting them there are others
that want transparency because they feel
that if they are really doing the right
things and they're gonna have a
competitive advantage